.
WHAT WE'VE SEEN LAID OUT THIS
WEEK SHOWS THAT IT'S WORSE THAN
WE COULD HAVE IMAGINED.
>> MATT GAETZ, PERHAPS THE
LEADER OF THE REBELS, THE MOST
VIRULENT, ANTI KEVIN
CONGRESSMAN WALKING OFF THE
FLOOR OF THE HOUSE,
ACKNOWLEDGING MCCARTHY WILL
LIKELY BECOME SPEAKER.
HE SAID, WE BASICALLY --
HE WILL LIKELY WIN BUT WE
FITTED HIM IN A NICE STRAIGHT
JACKET.
>> WHAT A WAY TO START TO
GOVERN.
TO YOUR POINT, THERE ARE MORE
OF THESE MEMBERS WHO ARE LIKE
CONGRESSMAN STEWART.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT WAS GIVEN
AWAY.
WHEN WE ALL SET OUT TOGETHER
THE FIRST TIME, A YEAR AGO,
WHENEVER THAT WAS, I THINK THE
WORD I USED WAS UGLY.
THIS IS AN UGLY WAY TO GET TO
BE SPEAKER.
I THINK WE HAVE SEEN THAT THIS
WEEK.
I THINK IT'S ALSO GOING TO BE
AN UGLY WAY TO CONTINUE.
>> IT IS AN UGLY WAY.
KEVIN MCCARTHY, HE SAID IT
AFTER HE CAME OUT THERE, THAT
HE HAS THE VOTES.
HE SAID HE HAS THE VOTES.
HE SAYS HE CAN COUNT.
THAT'S THE BIG TEST.
CAN HE COUNT?
IS THAT THE LESSON HE LEARNED?
TO GO BACK IN TIME A LITTLE BIT,
HIS INITIAL STRATEGY THIS --
BY A LOT.
YOU DO NOT TAKE SOMETHING TO
THE FLOOR WHEN YOU ARE GOING TO
LOSE ON 14 BALLOTS, YOU JUST
DON'T.
YOU HAVE TO NEGOTIATE
BEFOREHAND.
LET'S SEE IF HE LEARNED THAT
LESSON.
>> I WANT TO GO BACK TO THE
INTERVIEWS YOU MENTIONED.
I THINK THAT'S THE FASCINATING
PART GOING FORWARD.
THIS IS JUST ABOUT PERSONNEL,
WHO LEADS US.
NOW HE HAS TO DEAL WITH A WHOLE
HOST OF VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES.
A NARROW MAJORITY, A DIVIDED
GOVERNMENT, A DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENT AND SENATE, WHETHER
IT'S UKRAINE SPENDING, WHETHER
IT'S RAISING THE DEBT LIMIT,
THERE WILL BE MORE IMMIGRATION
ISSUES AND MORE GOVERNING
CONSERVATIVES.
FRENCH HILL, CHRIS STEWART,
FITZPATRICK ON EARLIER, THEY
WANT TO TRY TO GOVERN.
THEY ARE WILLING TO TALK TO
DEMOCRATS.
THE WIGGLING --
THE QUESTION IS, AFTER THIS
HOSTAGE CRISIS OF THE LAST FOUR
DAYS, IF YOU DO THEY HAVE ANY
MORE ROOM TO DO THAT?
DO THEY HAVE LESS ROOM TO DO
THAT?
IS EVERYBODY BRUISED ENOUGH TO
SAY LET'S STOP FIGHTING AND
GIVE THIS A CHANCE?
YOU CAN SEE IT.
WE'VE TALKED A LOT ABOUT THE
REBELS AND THE HOLDOUTS AND HOW
THEY ARE ANTI GOVERNMENT.
HOW THEY ARE ANTI-ESTABLISHMENT,
SYSTEM, ANTI-DEMOCRACY IN SOME
WAY.
THEY ARE REALIZING THEY ARE AND
--
CONGRESSMAN STEWART, THEY ARE
THOUGHTFUL PEOPLE.
THEY ARE POLITE.
DEMOCRATS SAY WE DISAGREE WITH.
HIM --
HOW DID SHE FIGURE THIS OUT
WITH A NARROW MAJORITY?
THERE ARE A LOT OF THOUGHTFUL
POLICY BASED REPUBLICANS WHO
UNDERSTAND THE PREDICAMENT, THE
DIVIDED GOVERNMENT WITH A TINY
MAJORITY, WHO STILL WANT TO DO
SOME THINGS.
CAN THEY?
>> WE STILL DON'T FULLY KNOW
WHAT HAPPENS BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS AND WHAT THEIR
CONCESSIONS.
ARE WE DON'T HAVE A FINALIST.
WE KNEW WHAT IT LOOKED LIKE
YESTERDAY WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT
HOW MUCH IT DIMINISHED THE
POWER THAT KEVIN MCCARTHY WILL
HAVE IF HE IS SAYING THE TRUTH
TONIGHT.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT WILL
LOOK LIKE.
I'M STILL CURIOUS WHICH MEMBERS
IT IS THAT HE BELIEVES WILL
CROSS THE LINE.
BECAUSE ELI CRANE AND MATT
ROSENTHAL, THE TWO WE ARE
SPEAKING OF, I'M TOLD, ARE THE
TOP THREE OF THE MOST OPPOSED
TO KEVIN MCCARTHY.
WHAT IS HE GIVING THEM?
WHAT IS IT GOING TO LOOK LIKE?
WE'VE BEEN ON THE HILL THIS
WEEK SPEAKING TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
MCCARTHY SUPPORTERS, THEY SAID,
HE WILL STILL BE AN EFFECTIVE
SPEAKER, HE'S CERTAINLY NOT
GOING TO BE POWERFUL.
THEY WANTED THE POWER TO BE
RETURNED TO THE MEMBERS.
THAT'S WHAT A LOT OF THEM
AGREED ON.
AND WHEN THEY LOOKED AT THIS.
A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE AS, I WAS
SAYING EARLIER, A LOT OF THEM
ARE NEW MEMBERS.
A LOT OF THEM, EVEN IF NOT NEW
MEMBERS, HAVE NEVER BEEN IN A
MAJORITY BEFORE.
THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW THAT LOOKS
LIKE.
THAT WILL ALSO BE THIS WHOLE
NEW WORLD FOR THEM.
THIS IS THE EASIEST VOTE THEY
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE TAKING.
LOOK HOW LONG IT'S TAKEN.
>> CAN I PLAY DEVILS ADVOCATE
ABOUT HOW THIS PLAYED OUT?
AND THERE IS SOME PSYCHOLOGY IN
THE REPUBLICAN CONFERENCE ABOUT
VOTING AGAINST KEVIN MCCARTHY.
I THINK THERE WERE SOME PEOPLE
WHO NEEDED TO CAST A VOTE
AGAINST KEVIN MCCARTHY TO BE
ABLE TO GO THE OTHER WAY OR, IN
THE CASE OF SOME OF THE SIX WHO
ARE REMAINING, SOME MIGHT NEVER
BE ABLE TO CAST A VOTE FOR
KEVIN MCCARTHY.
IF YOU ARE MCCARTHY, YOU
PROBABLY KNOW THAT ABOUT SOME
OF YOUR MEMBERS, THAT YOU HAVE
TO GET TO THE VOTES, YOU HAVE
TO GO THROUGH THIS EXERCISE, AS
PAINFUL AS IT WAS.
I'M JUST SAYING, I DON'T THINK
NANCY PELOSI WOULD HAVE EVER
GOTTEN TO THIS POINT.
I ALSO THINK HE'S DEALING WITH
A CROP OF PEOPLE.
>> WE DON'T KNOW THE
CONCESSIONS ARE.
IN THE 1970S, AFTER ALL THIS EA
A ACCESSES, THE CHURCH
COMMITTEE, THEY LOOKED INTO THE
CIA ACCESS AND PUT SOME
GUIDELINES AND RESTRICTIONS IN
PLACE.
THERE IS A DESIRE AMONG THE
FREEDOM CAUCUS FOLKS AND THE
REBELS TO HAVE A CHURCH STYLE
COMMITTEE LOOKING AT THE FBI
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
IF THE BIG FEAR ALONG
ESTABLISHMENT REPUBLICANS IS
THAT THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE
THE CHURCH COMMITTEE.
THIS IS GOING TO BE AN EFFORT
BY INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE DEFIED
CONGRESSIONAL SUBPOENAS FROM
THE JANUARY 6TH INVESTIGATION
TO ACTUALLY OBSTRUCT JUSTICE
FROM THE, WITH A GAVEL IN THEIR
HANDS, FROM A COMMITTEE.
THERE ARE REAL FEARS HERE.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT ONE OF
THEM.
SCOTT PERRY, WHOSE PHONE WAS
TAKEN BY THE FBI.
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
INCLUDING KEVIN MCCARTHY, WHO
IS ABOUT TO BECOME SPEAKER, IT
APPEARS, WHO DEFIED THE
SUBPOENA.
THE OTHER GROUP THAT I HEAR
ABOUT IS THERE ARE SUPPOSEDLY
STILL REPUBLICAN DEFENSE HAWKS.
REPUBLICANS WHO CARE ABOUT
NATIONAL SECURITY.
THEY MAY HAVE GIVEN UP A LOT OF
MONEY.
>> 75 BILLION DOLLARS.
>> 75 BILLION DOLLARS IN
DEFENSE SPENDING.
HOW DO THEY LIVE WITH THAT?
>> THE THING WITH THAT, I WILL
SAY, IS THAT IT'S NOT ENTIRELY
UP TO THEM.
FINDING OUR DEFENSE DEPARTMENT
IS A WHOLE GOVERNMENT
ENTERPRISE THAT ALSO INVOLVES
REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE THAT
IS STILL NOT QUITE AS FAR GONE
AS THE HOUSE REPRESENTATIVES.
I THINK THERE IS A QUESTION
ABOUT WE WILL SEE IF THESE
HARD-LINERS REALLY ACTUALLY
WANT THE CONCESSIONS THEY THINK
THEY DID.
>> IT BEARS REPEATING THAT
TODAY'S JANUARY 6TH.
WE WATCHED EARLIER THE
PRESIDENTS HAVE THAT CEREMONY
WHERE HE GAVE HONORS TO PEOPLE
WHO DEFENDED DEMOCRACY.
MAYBE, BY THE END OF THE DAY ON
JANUARY 6TH, KEVIN MCCARTHY
WILL BE SPEAKER.
IT WAS TWO YEARS AGO THAT SOME
OF THESE HOLDOUTS --
HELPED STAGE A VIOLENT COUP.
IT ALMOST TOOK DOWN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> IF HE BECOMES SPEAKER ON THE
ANNIVERSARY OF THE JANUARY 6TH
INSURRECTION, I JUST DON'T
THINK WE SHOULD LET THAT GO.
>> LATE AT NIGHT TO FINISH
THEIR BUSINESS TWO YEARS LATER.
>> CAN I GO BACK TO THE DEFENSE
THING FOR A SECOND?
I WANT TO GIVE REVELS CREDIT
FOR THAT.
I THINK IT WAS SENATOR FRED
THOMPSON WHO ONCE SAID, NOBODY
WHO HAS EVER BEEN TO THE
PENTAGON THINKS THAT THEY COULD
NOT HAVE SOME OF THEIR BUDGET
CUT.
>> HAVE NOT SEEN THE WEST WING
EPISODE WHERE THEY THROW THE
ASHTRAY AT THE WALL?
>> THE IDEA THAT THEY WANT TO
CUT DEFENSE SPENDING, WHICH IS
REALLY IN THEIR VIEW, I'M
TALKING ABOUT THE VIEW OF THE
REBELS, CUTTING MONEY GOING TO
DEFENSE CONTRACTORS, CUTTING
MONEY GOING TO FIND WHAT
EISENHOWER WARNED WAS THE
MILITARY INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX,
THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH ACTUAL
WANTING TO DRAIN THE SWAMP.
IT IS.
IN GENERAL, REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN RELUCTANT
TO TOUCH THAT BUDGET,
ESPECIALLY REPUBLICANS.
I GIVE THEM CREDIT FOR THAT.
>> CAMILLE SKEPTICAL THAT THIS
ONE STICKS FOR A COUPLE OF
REASONS.
FIRST OF ALL, DEMOCRATS WOULD
LOVE WHAT YOU ARE DESCRIBING.
THEY HAVE BEEN ASKING FOR THAT
FOR A LONG TIME.
--
I THINK THAT PARTICULAR ONE
DEMOCRATS WOULD BE ALL FOR IT.
THIS IS HAPPENING AT THE SAME
TIME THAT REPUBLICANS IN BOTH
CHANGERS ARE TRYING TO MAKE THE
ARGUMENT THAT BIDEN DEMOCRATS
ARE TOO SOFT ON CHINA, BIDEN
AND THE DEMOCRATS ARE NOT
WILLING TO FUND THE MILITARY
ENOUGH.
I DON'T THINK, TO CASEY'S POINT,
AND AS I SAID BEFORE, MCCARTHY
IS GIVING WAY THINGS THAT HE
DOESN'T HAVE THE POWER TO GIVE
AWAY.
HE'S BASICALLY JUST SAYING TO
THEM, THIS IS GOING TO BE OUR
STARTING NEGOTIATING POSITION.
IF YOU ARE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE, WHETHER A DEMOCRAT
OR A MODERATE REPUBLICAN, ALL
THAT SAYS TO YOU IS THAT THIS
IS WHERE THEY ARE GOING TO
START.
WE ARE JUST NOT GOING TO DO
THAT.
WE WILL DIVIDE AND CONQUER AND
MOVE FORWARD WITH ANOTHER PLAN.
I THINK IT JUST SHOWS
MCCARTHY'S WEAKNESS, IT SHOWS
HIS HANDS.
I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
THAT HARD FOR A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS IN THE HOUSE OR THE
SENATE TO JUST STEAMROLL RIGHT
OVER THAT.
>> ON THE DEFENSE QUESTION, I
TAKE YOUR POINT ABOUT THE
DEFENSE CONTRACTORS AND
OVERSPENDING, ET CETERA.
I THINK THIS IS MORE ABOUT
ISOLATIONIST STRAIN THAT WE
HAVE SEEN IN THE POPULIST
REPUBLICAN PARTY THAN ABOUT
ANYTHING ELSE.
>> YOU THINK IT'S ABOUT THE
SWAMP?
WE DON'T NEED A BIG MILITARY
OVERSEAS.
>> RIGHT.
I THINK IT HAS MORE TO DO WITH
THE FACT THAT A LOT OF TRUMP
SUPPORTERS IN THE POPULACE,
MAINLY THE GOP, AND THIS HAS
BEEN A STRAIN IN AMERICAN
PUBLIC LIFE FOR OVER A CENTURY,
JUST GET US OUT OF THEIR.
WE DON'T WANT TO BE INVOLVED.
THAT RAND PAUL'S OF THE WORLD.
I THINK THAT'S A LOT OF WHAT IT
IS.
THAT'S A HUGE IDEOLOGICAL
DIVIDE INSIDE THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
THEY ARE STILL A VERY STRONG,
TOPPLING IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
PEOPLE ARE FOCUSED ON THIS AS
SOMETHING THAT MCCARTHY MAY
HAVE, SEEMS TO HAVE GIVEN AWAY
IN ANGER, THE SIGNIFICANT,
IMPORTANT CHUNK OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN SUPPORTING IT THIS
FAR.
>> COULD I ASK CAITLIN, WE HAVE
NOT SAID THE TEA WERE TODAY.
DONALD TRUMP.
>> I WAS THINKING, SHOULD I
BRING IT UP?
>> WE KNOW THAT IF THIS GOES
ACCORDING TO KEVIN MCCARTHY'S
PLAN TONIGHT AND HE DOES BECOME
HOUSE SPEAKER IN A FEW HOURS,
TRUMP WILL COME IN AND TAKE
CREDIT.
I DON'T THINK THAT WOULD BE
SURPRISING TO ANY PERSON ON
THIS PANEL.
IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT WE SAID
EARLIER TRUMP WAS CALLING THESE
HOLDOUTS THIS MORNING.
HE'S PROBABLY STILL CALLING
SOME OF THEM NOW.
HE'S NOT THE REASON THEIR VOTES
WERE CHANGED.
BUT --
WE ARE GOING TO ASK, WHAT WERE
THE CONCESSIONS, WHAT DOES IT
LOOK LIKE?
WE WILL FIND OUT ONCE THIS IS
PASSED.
TRUMP DID NOT HAVE THE
INFLUENCE HE SOUGHT TO HAVE.
IF HE HAD, WHAT'S HAPPENING
TODAY WOULD'VE HAPPENED ON
TUESDAY.
IT DIDN'T.
IT TOOK MUCH LONGER.
I THINK THAT'S PART OF THIS.
TRUMP IS STILL A FACTOR IN THIS,